buenas tardes desde londres y aumenta
esta crisis de credibilidad y autoridad
del primer ministro boris johnson por lo
que ya se conoce como el partido gheit
mientras sectores del partido laborista
de oposición piden que dé un paso al
costado su propio partido el conservador
algunas voces ya han dicho que esta
situación es indefendible luego de que
se conociera que el 20 de mayo de 2020
también se realizó una fiesta en los
jardines de la residencia del primer
ministro
el partido laborista citó a una moción a
un debate de urgencia en el parlamento a
la que esperaba preguntarle al primer
ministro sobre esta polémica no asistió
de lejos a un ministro júnior para su
respuesta así que tendremos que esperar
a mañana las preguntas al primer
ministro en el parlamento para conocer
su versión lo cierto es que en las
últimas horas se conoció exactamente que
el 20 de mayo en la tarde se habría
realizado una fiesta el secretario
privado del primer ministro envió un
correo electrónico al menos a 100
trabajadores de downing street- del
complejo de la sede del gobierno para
invitarlos a ésta a la que habría que
llevar sus propios tragos se reporta que
boris johnson y su esposa asistieron
pese a que ha negado el primer ministro
en repetidas ocasiones haber roto las
reglas del confinamiento y es que en
mayo de 2020 este país se encontraba aún
en un estricto confinamiento solo se
podría haber alguna persona que no con
la que no se conviviera a dos metros de
distancia y en los exteriores y también
crece la rabia la furia entre la
población que a través de redes sociales
ha expuesto en mensajes y también en
fotos como vivió ese 20 de mayo de 2020
especialmente mensajes muy tristes de
personas que no pudieron despedir a sus
seres queridos que murieron ese día por
kobe 19